c'est bonsoir merci nous accordé cette
entrevue en soi mais tu sais on sait que
le pétrole albertain coûte plus cher à
produire que le pétrole conventionnel
traditionnelle alors avec la guerre des
prix à laquelle on assiste en ce moment
combien de temps encore va t'il être
rentable ce pétrole des sables
bitumineux
elle est certain que les prochaines et
divertit prochaine en exploitation
aujourd'hui en alberta sont moins
rentables aujourd'hui avec les du
pétrole qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
mais il faut aussi voir que presque
toute la production albertaine
aujourd'hui demeure rentable profitable
même au public on voit aujourd'hui est
donc pour le moment les projets
continuent la production n'a pas baissé
du tout on a plus on n'a pas baissé et
mène l'opposition on compte voire
l'abolition augmenter dans les
prochaines années
parce que la majorité de la production
albertaine aujourd'hui est issu des
soldes diminuer les projets de sables
bitumineux sont des des énormes projets
de toutes tailles et c'est très
différent de la production
conventionnelle qu'on connaissait
d'antan ou en faudrait 1 1 puis on
d'exploiter le puits donc changer de
production lieu d'investir massivement
dans les gros projets de sables
bitumineux
ce sont vraiment des complexes
industriels de dizaines de milliards de
drams et donc une fois que ça commence à
produire
on ne regarde que les coûts variables
pour déterminer si on consulte
l'exploitation mais en même temps est-ce
qui est encore un marché pour ce pétrole
des sables bitumineux dans la mesure où
le principal marché ce sont les états
unis les états unis deviennent de plus
en plus autosuffisant et c'est un marché
encore pour ce pétrole albertain
les etats unis demeurent un important
importateur net au niveau pétroliers et
savoir se mettre le corps probablement à
tout jamais les états unis ne dit on pas
être autosuffisant au niveau pétroliers
si on se limite au pétrole et donc qu'il
ya probablement un marché aujourd'hui
qui est presque aussi intéressant pour
les productions canadiennes avec les
symptômes mais pour les pétrolières pour
lille la production combien de temps
encore elles peuvent tenir le coup si le
prix du baril demeure bord pendant 1
en deux ans trois ans personne n'a l'air
de vraiment le savoir parce que les
règles du marché en l'air d'avoir un peu
changé combien de temps est-ce qu'elles
peuvent tenir
moi je pense que la plupart des
entreprises qui produisent aujourd'hui
dans le secteur des sables bitumineux
peuvent continuer à produire au prix
actuel pendant pendant plusieurs années
pendant des décennies elle prendra
évidemment d'édition niveau du
resserrement des coûts pour améliorer la
profitabilité de leurs opérations
mais ces opérations là il faut
comprendre qu'il ya un coût fixe très
très important qui était investi dans
cette entreprise manufacturière qui est
un projet de saab diminue et que les
coûts variables
quoique étant toujours assez important
les coûts variables sont sont toujours
couverts par les petits qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et on en dit quoi on dit que
ça leur coûte entre 31 dollars à
produire et donc tout ce qui est au
dessus c'est un peu des profits est ce
que c'est ça en gros c'est ça de façon
très simple de façon simplifiée le 31 $
ça puisse s'appliquer à certaines
entreprises pas d'autres à certains
projets pas d'autre mais sont tout vous
avez raison que ça demeure profiteurs et
la marge de profit le maire de paris
la marge de profit beaucoup moins grande
ce qui veut dire que les entreprises
vont vont payer leurs investissements en
coûts fixes beaucoup moins rapidement
il ya moins d'argent pour les redevances
pour le gouvernement
et il ya bien sûr beaucoup moins
d'incitations à investir davantage dans
des projets d'expansion ou de nouveaux
projets ceci dit moi je demeure
optimiste au niveau de ce marché lot du
marché pétrolier dans le court terme au
niveau global
ne serait ce que parce que jusqu'à peu
décembre marqué d énormément
d'investissements malgré énormément de
bonne foi malgré énormément d'incitation
on n'a pas encore trouvé de combustible
de technologies de remplacement qui peut
de façon efficace et dans une mesure
acceptée par le marché oui si tu sais
merci beaucoup
vous en paierez
merci